it's crazy too because like i just feel
like
um
you know what what i appreciate about
what eminem does
on shady is
it's not about
cloud politics it's like who's dope
yeah like who like
boogie is dope right right grzelda guys
fight like people forget when eminem
brought griselda to shady like griselda
was buzzing and like
like amongst the hip-hop heads like
boom-bap kids but it was nothing like it
is now yeah like
he's super early on you yeah do you know
what i'm saying
and i think it's dope because like
a lot of times we'll see a lot of these
executives or artist turns executives
and it's really about like
it's really not it's not as much about
the talent in the capabilities as a
rapper as it is about like
the dollar signs you know what i'm
saying yeah man i think that's one of
the things when talking to him
of course i know it's a business you
know of course like when i talk to him
and [ __ ] it's like
you still felt like he was he's an
artist and like he kind of just like you
know what i'm saying it's like it's like
it's like a coach who used to play
basketball yeah
you know it's like it's a difference
it's a difference a coach who played in
the nba yeah they got different
different respect with the players
that's why you always hear like yeah man
this guy feel me ex-player always gets
the locker room easier you feel me like
so like i felt that
you know i mean i felt that like before
we even
any paperwork anything you know i mean
he was just like yo like i don't want to
change nothing like i
you know i mean like pretty much that's
just great you creative control so it's
just like cool so you have creative
control in your situation yeah oh that's
fire that's big that's huge that's very
also very uh un
uncommon
yeah for real